CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger Jill good morning good
morning we heard Larry Kudlow just say
nothing's happened but then we also
heard the Treasury Secretary say there
could be a trade war how close to a
trade war are we actually I think of
this as like a boxing match right and
and we had a little bit of that
pre-match chatter in the beginning and
we had round one back-and-forth which
has been enacted and round two occurred
this week fifty billion dollars on each
side back and forth those second-round
actions have not been implemented yet
and the president even said on Thursday
hey could be another hundred billion
that we start levying some tariffs on so
we're early in this we are not at a war
I would say it's at if headed towards a
conflict and we really hope that this is
not going to get there trade wars are
really bad what happens with a trade war
both sides see prices rise central banks
raise interest rates we see a lot of
consumer pain and usually heads into a
recession I'm running that down at if
towards economy like that actly where
that goes yeah we also heard from the
president that it's sort of the short
term pain but it will be long term gain
that that's fine if you're not a pork
farmer or a soybean farmer what does
that really mean for what may be ahead
right and I think that's also fine if
you're not a consumer as to pay higher
prices so I think the reality is that if
we get to a negotiated place with the
Chinese where there are fair trade deals
that would be a good thing and if all of
this bluster lasts a couple of weeks or
maybe six to eight weeks we can take it
if it starts heading in two months and
we are now talking about this in the
summer it's likely the stock market will
be much lower
it will also be likely that consumers
and businesses get their confidence
shaken and I think that can actually
have a real negative impact on the
economy the markets already taking a hit
here all the gains of the year wiped out
all three major indexes and negative
territory at this point and the Chinese
are saying they will fight at any cost
yeah that's a little disturbing there's
you know we have a trade imbalance right
we import a lot more Chinese goods about
five hundred five billion compared to
the hundred and thirty billion or so we
send over there so we can't go
tit-for-tat in a
way they could look at doing other
things they could make doing business
for American companies service companies
in China much more difficult they could
even say to Chinese consumers hey let's
do a boycott on US goods or let's not
have you travel to the US as much those
more subtle measures can have a negative
impact on this look this is not a good
thing overall it breeds anxiety
uncertainty is the enemy of every
investor that's what we've seen in the
market obviously alright Jill
Schlesinger thank you we appreciate it